ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้สวัสดีครับน้องเรียม
สวัสดีครับนักเรียนด้วยสวัสดีครับสนุก
ครับครับผม
เครียดสิคะวันนี้มันอะไรค่ะวันนี้ที่เรา
จะมาเรียนกันใช่ไหมครับวันนี้วันที่เท่า
ไหร่ครับวันนี้วันจันทร์ใช่วันนี้วัน
จันทร์นะครับวันนี้วันจันทร์เดี๋ยวปากกา
วันนี้วันจันทร์นี้ครับวันนี้วันว้าววัน
จันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันจันทร์วันที่
23 ครับนี่วันนี้วันที่
13 วันจันทร์ที่ 13 ครับวันนี้เดือนอะไร
คะอ่อเดือนอะไรเดือนนี้เดือน
กันยายนครับหน้าเดือนกันยายนอาหาร
เต็มที่ศักราชปีคริสตศักราช
2000  0  21 ครับหน้าปีนี้วันนี้วัน
จันทร์ที่ 13 เดือนกันยายนนะครับ 5 ปี
คริสต์ศักราช
2021 เย้วันๆวันนี้วันจันทร์ครับ
ตอนนี้เครียดอี้อยู่ที่ไหนคะวันนี้พี่
อาร์ตี้อยู่ที่บ้านครับเจ๊ที่อยู่ที่บ้าน
ใช่หน้าแล้วน้องเรียมน้องเรียนอยู่ที่ไหน
ครับ
เตรียมก็อยู่ที่บ้านหมออยู่ที่บ้านเหมือน
กันเราเราทั้งสองคนอยู่ที่บ้านพี่อาร์ตี้
อยู่ที่บ้านของพี่อาร์ตี้อ่ะน้องเรียม
อยู่ที่บ้านของน้องเรียมอยู่ที่บ้านของ
พ่อกับแม่แม่เรียกร้อรออยู่ที่บ้านของพ่อ
กับแม่
ใช่อ๋อมีพ่อคุณแม่
อ๋ออ๋อแล้วก็มีดีอ่ะมีน้องหรือยัง
อ๋อน้องเรียนเป็นลูกเป็นลูกของพ่อกับแม่
โอเค
เตรียมก็อยู่ในบ้าน
บ้านของพ่อกับแม่อ๋อ
โอเคเตรียมอยู่ในบ้านของพ่อกับแม่ครับใช่
ค่ะอ้าเดี๋ยวนี้
เตรียมก็อยากมีบ้าน
ของตัวเองอ๋ออยากมีบ้านของตัวเอง
ครับผมวันนี้เราก็เลยจะพูดถึงบ้านในฝัน
อ๋ออ๋อบ้านในฝันของเรียมที่เรียมอยากจะมี
อะไรอยากจะมีบ้านขายเองอ่ะเอา k55 เดี๋ยว
เราไปดูกันว่าบ้านในฝันของเรียมเนี่ยจะ
เป็นยังไงคะเดี๋ยวนักเรียนวันนี้เราไปดู
บ้านของน้องเรียงกันแล้วบ้านในฝันของ
เรียนกันนะอ่า
หาในฝันเนี่ยน้องเรียมอยากได้บ้านแบบไหน
ครับ
เตรียมอยากได้บ้าน
หลายๆชั้นอ๋ออ๋อบ้านหลายๆชั้นห่าแบบนี้
อ้าอันนี้ในรูปนี้รูปนี้เป็นบ้านอันนี้
เป็นบ้าน 1 ชั้นเขามีอยู่ชั้นเดียวใช่ไหม
อ๋อนี่บ้านชั้นเดียวนี่ชั้นเดียวนะครับ
อ้าวแล้วอันนี้อันนี้กี่ชั้นครับเนี่ย
สองชั้นอันนี้มี 2 ชั้นครับนี่เป็นบ้าน 2
ชั้นอ๋ออ๋อเคเป็นบ้านสองชั้นอันนี้ 1
ชั้น
อันนี้
2 ชั้นว้าวแล้วบ้านในฝันบ้านในฝันของโรง
เรียนเนี่ยแล้วก็เทียมอยากมีบ้านกี่ชั้น
ครับพี่ตัวฉันยังอยากมีบ้าน 5 ชั้น ka
ศาลเลยเหรอครับ
ใช่ค่ะเรียมอยากมีบ้าน 555 ถ้าฉัน 5 สูง
ขึ้นไปที่ 5 ฉันเลย
ฉันที่สอง
ชั้นที่ 3 ว้าวแผนที่ 4 และชั้นที่ 5  6
บ้านแล้วหรือหลายชั้นมากมี 5 ชั้นเลยโอเค
ครับ 5 แล้วที่บ้านมีอะไรอีกครับ
บ้านก็จะมีประตู
มีประตูอยู่ด้วยประตูมีประตูอยู่ด้านหน้า
บ้านเลยใช่ไหมครับนี่ประตูแบบนี้ใช่ไหม
อ่ามีประตู
ประตูที่อาทิที่ที่พี่อาร์ตี้ชี้อยู่เปิด
ประตูบานเปิดขอเบอร์การเปิดออกมาล็อคเปิด
ออกมาแบบนี้เราก็เดินเข้าไปในบ้านได้โอเค
ประตูบานเปิดครับ
บ้าน
บ้านของเรียมเป็นประตูบานเลื่อนหมอเป็น
ประตูบานเลื่อนแบบนี้ครับอ๋อก็คือมันจะ
เลื่อนไปใช่ไหมค่ะเลื่อนเลื่อนไปทางนี่
นั่นไปทางนี้อาจเลื่อนไปทางซ้ายหรือ
เลื่อนไปทางขวาก็ได้อ๋อเวลาเลื่อนเสร็จ
แล้วเนี่ยเราก็จะเดินเข้าไปทางนี้ใช่ไหม
เดินเข้าไปค่ะได้ไม่รู้เอาใหม่อันนี้
เรียกว่าประตูอะไรนะครับ
ประตูบานเลื่อนประตูบานเลื่อนน้องเคเค
เป็นบานเลื่อนเลื่อนไปเลื่อนไปหน้าเรื่อง
ใจเราบ้านมาเรียมก็มีหน้าต่างเขามี
หน้าต่างด้วยใช่ๆครับบ้านพี่อาร์ตี้ก็มี
หน้าต่างเหมือนกันอ่ะบ้านน้องเรียมก็กี่
นัดข้างด้วยว้าวเดี๋ยวนะพี่หารูปหน้าต่าง
ก่อนหน้าต่างหน้าต่างน่าจะเป็นอ่าสี่
เหลี่ยมแบบนี้ใช่ไหมครับอ๋อนี่รูปนี้ใช้
ได้ไหมพรุ่งนี้ใช้ได้ไหมอ๊อดใช้ได้นะโอเค
นี่เป็นหน้าต่างอ่าเห็นหน้าต่างบ้านที่
บ้านก็ต้องมีหน้าต่างด้วยอ่ะใช่แล้ว
หน้าต่างเราใช้ทำอะไรครับ
ใช้เอาไว้ทำอะไร
ระบายอากาศขอระบายอากาศอ๋อให้อากาศเข้ามา
ทางหน้าตามากจ้าๆโอเคแล้วอันนี้อะไรครับ
เนี่ย
ถ้าม่านแดงออกเป็นผ้าม่านผ้าม่านน้อ
จะใช้ทำอะไรครับ
พม่าเอาไว้กันแดดขอไว้กันแดดเวลามีแสงแดด
เข้ามาใช่ไหมครับใกล้ค่ะอ๋อก็ลึกม่านมา
แล้วก็ปิดตรงนี้ใช่ไหมปิด
ใช่คะอ๋ออ๋อแดดก็จะไม่เข้ามาแล้ว
ว่าอ๋ออ๋อมีผ้าม่านและโอเคแต่เวลาที่เรา
ต้องการให้อากาศเข้ามาเราก็เปิดผ้าม่าน
ออกใช่ไหมเปิดพม่าเราก็เปิดผ้าม่านออกแบบ
นี้ว้าวดีค่ะหน้า
5 แล้วเนี่ยให้ลมให้มาอยากให้ลงเข้ามา
ก็ต้องเปิดหน้าต่างขอเปิดหน้าต่างออกไป
ขอเคเปิดต่างออกไปให้ลมเข้ามาได้ว่าว้าว
ดีจังมีหน้าต่างเยอะเลยบ้านน้องเปิด
หน้าต่างเยอะเลย
ใช่ค่ะดูมีหน้าต่างกี่บานขอ
1 งาน
2 บาน
สามพราน 4 บาน 5 บานอ้าวมีหน้าต่าง 5 บาน
เลยนะครับโอเค
แล้วที่บ้านมีหน้าต่างแล้วมีอะไรอีกครับ
ที่บ้านก็จะมีห้อง
ครัวอ๋ออ๋อมีห้องครัวอยู่ที่บ้านด้วยห้อง
ครัวห้องครัวนี่เราเอาไว้ทำอะไรครับใน
ห้องครัวใช่อันนี้ไหมนี่กลัวใช่ค่ะห้อง
ครัวห้องครัว
มีห้องครัวของเราใช่ไหมครับใช่ค่ะขอครัว
ของเรียมอยู่ชั้น 2
หอห้องครัวอยู่ชั้น 2 นะครับได้ค่ะอ๋อ
ห้องครัวนี่รอไว้ทำอาหารใช่ไหมครับทำ
อาหารอีกอ้าใช่กินในห้องครัวแค่หาแล้วใน
ห้องครัวนนับมีโต๊ะโต๊ะกินข้าวห้องครัวมี
โต๊ะกินข้าวอันนี้นี่คือโต๊ะ
ครับโต๊ะกินข้าวใช่ไหมอ่าแล้วก็มี
เก้าอี้
อ๋ออ๋ออันนี้นี่คือเก้าอี้
อ้ามีเก้าอี้กี่ตัวครับ
มีเก้าอี้อยู่ 4 ตัว E  4 ตัว
เก้าอี้ 4 ตัวตัว 2 เก้าอี้ 3 รายการที่ 4
ตัวเอง A5 ครับแล้วก็มีเตา
รีดเอาด้วยนี่เตาว้าวมีเตาเธออยู่ตรงนี้
เขาใช้เตาไฟเตาฝ่ายก็เวลาที่เราใช้งานมัน
ก็จะมีไฟขึ้นมาใช่ไหมอ่ะอ้ามีไปแบบนี้
โอเค
หน้ามีเตาไฟอยู่ในห้องครัวด้วยเมื่อกี้
พี่อ่าอ่ามีอ้อโอเคใช้มีอ่างด้วยนี่กำลัง
จะถามพอดีเลยพี่กำลังจะถามเลยนั้นคืออะไร
อาหารนี่คืออ่านเอาไว้ล้างจานออกเวลากิน
ข้าวเสร็จแล้วก็เอามาล้างที่อ่างนี้อ้า
ใช่เราล้าง
ครับในห้องครัวก็จะมีหม้ออ๋ออ๋อมีหม้อ
อยู่ในห้องครัวด้วยใช่ไหมๆเดี๋ยวพี่
อาร์ตี้นี่ไงนี่เราอยู่บนเตาเมื่อกี้นี้
คือเตาเมื่อกี้ใช่ไหมแล้วก็มีอันนี้นี่
ครับนี่คือหม้อ
หม้อ 5 มีหมออยู่นิครับอยู่ข้างๆและก็ก็
จะเป็นอันนี้ใช่ไหมครับ
กาต้มน้ำเป็นกาต้มน้ำกาต้มน้ำหอมเวลาที่
เราต้องการจะกินกาแฟใช่ไหมก็กินกาแฟแล้ว
ก็ต้องต้มน้ำชาใช่ต้มน้ำเวลาน้ำเดือดอ่ะ
ก็แสดงว่าน้ำเนี่ยร้อนและน้ำร้อนๆเอ้ยใช้
กาต้มน้ำหน้าครับไปค่ะข้างๆกาต้มน้ำข้าง
กาต้มน้ำกระทะอ๋ออันนี้สิไหมนี่กระทะ
กระทะโอเคว้าวหน้ากระทะทอดอ๋ออ๋อเอาไว้
ทอดทอดได้หลายอย่างเลยปะทะเอาไว้ช่อง Yeah
Yeah อาหารครับแล้วห้องต่อไปต้องต่อไป
อ่ะห้องที่อยู่ในบ้านในฝันของโรงเรียน
เดี๋ยวเราไปดูห้องต่อตัวที่น้องเรียมฝัน
อยากจะมีในบ้านก็คือเป็นห้องอะไรครับเป็น
ห้องอะไรครับอ๋อห้องต่อไปเป็นห้องนอนมี
ห้องนอนว่าห้องนอนอยู่แถวไหนครับน้อง
เหลี่ยมโรงเรียนเอาห้องนอนไว้ชั้นไหนของ
บ้าน
ห้องนอนอยู่ชั้น 5 หัวๆชั้น 5 ชั้น 5  5
ชั้นบนสุดเลยชั้นบนบนสุดเลยมีห้องนอนอยู่
ว้าว
หาค่ะแล้วในห้องนอนของเรียมก็มีเตียงนอน
มีเตียงนอนห้องนอนมีเตียงนอนเตียงนอนก็
คืออันนี้อ้านี่เตียงนอน
ว้าวเตียงนอนศิริญแล้วก็มีอะไรอีกครับมี
หมอนมีหมอนด้วยอ่านนี้มีคือหมอนครับอ้ามี
หมอน 2 ใบอยู่บนเตียงนอน
ใช่ค่ะแล้วก็มีคมไฟจี้โคมไฟด้วยว่าคงไป
อยู่ตรงไหนครับ
อยู่ตรงไฟอยู่ฟ้องโคมไฟอยู่ข้างๆเตียงอัน
นี้เป็นตีเรียง
ข้างๆเตียงก็คือตรงนี้นี่ครับนี่ Chrome
คบๆไปอยู่ตรงนี้ก็มีโคมไฟอยู่ข้างเตียง 2
ข้างเลย 2 ข้างเลยมีข้างนี้แล้วก็มีข้าง
นี้ด้วยอยู่ข้างขวา
ข้างขวา
และข้างซ้ายด้วย
5 ใช่ข้างขวาและข้างซ้ายมีโคมไฟโอเค
หัวหน้า
หาพี่ฉัน
ฉันวางของขอเป็นชั้นวางของเป็นแบบนี้นี่
นี่คือชั้นวางของเป็นชั้นมีชาร์จอันนี้ 1
ชั้น
มีอีกสองชั้นหน้าแล้ววางของบ้านของเรียม
ก็มีห้องทำงานอ๋อมีห้องทำงานด้วยว่าน้อง
เรียนต้องทำงานด้วยใช่ไหมแล้วต้องทำงาน
ด้วยเพราะฉะนั้นเราก็ต้องมีห้องสำหรับทำ
งานอ่ะห้องทำงานของเรียมอยู่ชั้น 3 หอ
อยู่ชั้น 3 ว้าวยี่ห้องทำงานอยู่ชั้น 3
น้องพยายามไปทำงานอยู่ในห้องทำงานขอ
เช้าทำงานของเตรียมอยู่ชั้น 3
ในห้องทำงานของเดียมจะมี
โอ๊ยน่อมีคอมพิวเตอร์อยู่ด้วยอ๋อ
คอมพิวเตอร์ก็คืออันนี้ใช่ไหมครับอ่านี่
คอมพิวเตอร์
อ่าอ๋ออ๋อคอมพิวเตอร์ก็เวลาเราทำงานเราก็
ต้องใช้คอมพิวเตอร์ในการทำงาน
เฮียตีก็ใช้คอมพิวเตอร์ทำงานเหมือนกันนะ
ครับแล้วข้างบนคอมพิวเตอร์ก็จะมีนาฬิกาบน
ทั้งบนก็คือด้านบนหน้าด้านบนมีนาฬิกา
ก็มีนาฬิกาอยู่นะครับอ่ะ
ใช่ค่ะมีโต๊ะโต๊ะทำงานโต๊ะทำงาน Auto ที่
เราใช้นั่งทำงานใช่ไหมที่เราใช้นั่งทำงาน
อันนี้นี่นี่นะทำงานเอออ้าวางคอมพิวเตอร์
ไว้บนโต๊ะๆวางคอมพิวเตอร์ไว้บนโต๊ะทำงาน
ว้าวโต๊ะทำอ่า
ของเรียมมีลิ้นชัก
มีลิ้นชักด้วยนี่นั้นนี้เรียกว่าลิ้นชัก
ลิ้นชัก 5 รอกสามารถดึงมันออกมาข้างนอก
ได้ดึงลิ้นเดิมอีกช้างหมอ
ว่างโต๊ะ
มีถังขยะหนอนนี้ใช่ไหมครับอันนี้มีอยู่
ข้างล่างนี้คอมพิวเตอร์อยู่ข้างบนถังขยะ
อยู่ข้างล่าง
น่าอยู่ข้างล่างตรงนี้นะครับถังขยะถังขยะ
เอาไว้ทำอะไรครับเอาไว้ทิ้งขยะอ๋ออ๋อทิ้ง
ขยะที่เราไม่ใช้แล้ว
โอเคนเรียนก็มีห้องน้ำอ๋อมีห้องน้ำอยู่ใน
บ้านด้วยใช่ไหมห้องในห้องน้ำอยู่ชั้นไหน
ครับ
ห้องน้ำอยู่ชั้น 4 ค่ะอ่าโอเคห้องน้ำอยู่
ฉันเช้าอยู่ชั้น 4 อ้าเดี๋ยวนะเฮียตี้
กำลังเดินขึ้นไปห้องน้ำอ่ะกำลังเดินขึ้น
ไปห้องน้ำห้องน้ำอยู่ชั้น 4 นะป่ะ
โอเคครับในห้องน้ำมีอะไรบ้างเยอะแยะเลย
ชักโครกมีทักโครกชักครอกคืออันนี้ใช่ไหม
ครับ
หน้ามีค่ะซักโครกอ่างล้างหน้าอ่างล้าง
หน้าออที่เราเอาไว้ล้างหน้าของเราอ้าล้าง
หน้านี่นี่คืออ่างล้างหน้า
มีกระจกกระจกกระจอก 5 นี้นี่เป็นกระจอก
กระจกเอาไว้สองเราจะได้มองเห็นตัวเรามอง
เห็นหน้าของเราอ่ะตอนที่เราล้างหน้าใช่
ไหมอ่าๆอ่าแฟลชจะออกโอเคพ่อแม่
แล้วก็มีอ่างอาบน้ำตัวนี้เป็นอ่างอ่าง
เหมือนกันแต่นี้เป็นอ่างอาบน้ำอาบน้ำโอเค
แค่มีอ่างอาบน้ำด้วยครับ
แล้วก็มีฝักบัวที่มีฝักบัวหัวฝักบัวอยู่
นี่นี่คือฝักบัวใช่ไหมอ่าๆเราอาบน้ำจาก
ฝักบัวเค
ในห้องน้ำของเรียมเครื่องฆ่ามีเครื่องซัก
ผ้าอยู่ในห้องน้ำด้วยเครื่องซักผ้าต้อง
เป็นอันนี้แน่ๆเลยนี่เพื่องซักผ้าใช่ไหม
อ๋อ
เครื่องซักผ้า
ครับ
แล้วในบ้านของเรียนม 5 ก็มีโรงรถมีโรงขอ
ดูรถด้วยว้าวเพราะว่าน้องเรียนมีรถก็ต้อง
มีที่ตอดรถหน้าที่ที่เราใช้จอดรถเรียกว่า
โรงจอด
ใช่ก็จอดโรงจอดรถอยู่ชั้นไหนครับอยู่ชั้น
1 ออกโอเคเดี๋ยวเราไปเจอกันที่ชั้นหนึ่ง
อ่ามาแล้วพี่ลงมาเดินลงมาครับเดินลงมา
ชั้น 1  5 นี่ครับมีรถจอดอยู่ที่ชั้น
หนึ่งนี่
บ้านน้องเรียมครับบ้านน้องเรียน 5 ชั้น
ฉันแล้วบ้านนักเรียนเหรอครับบ้านนักเรียน
มีกี่ชั้นครับเรียนอาจจะมี 6 ชั้นว่าเอ้า
โอเคเดี๋ยวเรามาคอยดูคอมเม้นกันว่าบ้าน
นักเรียนมีกี่ชั้นนะครับใช่ค่ะแล้วเดี๋ยว
เขาหน้าเรากลับมาเรียนภาษาไทยเก่าพี่น้อง
เหลี่ยมกับเพียร์ตีกันต่อๆวัน
สำหรับวันนี้ต้องขอขอบคุณและสวัสดีค่ะพี่
อาร์ตี้ขอบคุณมากแล้วก็สวัสดีครับแม่
สวัสดีน้องเรียนเปิดอยู่นักเรียนด้วยบ๊าย
บาย
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
k10 ชั้นติดฉัน